elijah i mentioned that you're going
back to the hobbit movies was there any
bit of you that kind of thought about it
because you must have been getting to a
bit in your life in your career where
people have stopped yelling frodo at you
in the street oh no oh really no that
doesn't matter never goes away pretty
perpetual thing oh okay so you can get a
table so you've got a table anywhere i'm
just wearing a ring it's
a ring yeah it's not a ring of power
though he doesn't like the ring it does
a bit doesn't it it's actually hebrew
precious
it is yeah oh okay yeah
and is it true and this seems unlikely
that you own a single piece of every bit
of memorabilia that they produced for
lord of the rings
oh well
that's half true so i've got a few
things from the actual film so i have
the ring i have sting
i have a map from um bilbo's study or
the living room and back end
and i just recently because i went back
and did the final bit on the hobbit
and they gave me the book that bilbo
writes in he writes the hobbit there in
mac again a hobbit's tale and then i
finish it as one of the rings they gave
me that red volume which is actual prop
yeah whoa and my last day in hobbiton it
was pretty
magical i know it's amazing
[Music]
so listen it's a re it's a real place
they've actually no it's not
[Applause]
we took all of the the facades away and
then it's since been a tourist
attraction and now it's been rebuilt for
the hobbit but with sustainable
materials with real woods so it'll
always be there
so from now on you'll actually get to
see hobbiton and visit it as a real
place
would you be able to you can't stay
there no you can't oh but they are
turning the green dragon covers
where's my bedroom
here's the jacuzzi
[Applause]
[Music]
i turned 19 when we first went to
hobbiton
and i'm 30 and i was talking to pete
when we were there on my last day i said
you realized that i had my 19th birthday
in hobbiton yeah not wild wow
that puts things into perspective
how many people can say that i had my
birthday party and hobbies
i was circumcised at disneyland
no one could have known that it was
going to take off and be
become a real place
good luck getting into new zealand
[Applause]
of you all at the premiere on monday
night oh yeah and i mean it's been part
of your life for night on 14 years now
so it must was that an emotional night
or were the emotions happened already
yeah well it's over you know we're not
not we've not been working on the hobbit
for some time now but i it was very
moving i mean you go and these kids have
been sleeping out all night what do you
know about this but the the the the
so we can get in
we're all homeless
these uh people were not born when we
started making uh lord of the rings you
know so it's it's a big part of their
lives and that's that's very very sweet
isn't it and they'll be able to see all
six movies now and show them to their
kids
that's what's nice we've made classics
that's lovely and also it will take
nearly a day to watch it
wood wood golem we're really sorry i'm
like poking with a stick but i want to
get my money's worth so er
could gollum introduce this lovely
where are my
faces it's time for music isn't it no
it's not shut your face
this is precious i love this singer for
so many years now you did not precious
what's your name precious her name is
addison
no and so i just we were hanging around
and we were in a very beautiful part of
new zealand where there was a sort of
mountain over there lovely sort of big
planes of lush green grass and it was it
was like a picturesque it was like a
a postcard of what how beautiful new
zealand can be but i said okay aidan if
there was a gun at your head you've got
to do one of these two things you've got
to either walk away from this scene not
saying anything to peter jackson or
anybody else you just gotta walk away
and go to
until you reach that mountain right and
not say anything to anyone and when they
say where's aidan he's got a line you'll
just be fired
that's over because no one will have
explained it and that be certainly this
job over and your name won't be you know
you wouldn't have done poldark that's
for sure no
um
or
you've got to
you've got to masturbate to completion
just in front of everyone here
and again
don't say anything about it yeah there's
no there's no introduction there's no
caveat
it's just um you've got to do one of the
if there was a gun ahead which one would
you do and he thought and he chose the b
he chose b
just because he figured he figured he
wouldn't get fired but he would get
fired
i don't think he's getting cold arc
after that either
you should be fired for that
yeah i mean i'm if there's one thing i
believe it's you should be fired for
wanking on set yeah yeah i'm all against
that i'm dead against that okay
that idea of of people knowing who you
were where where was it in the
supermarket when you had the yeah i was
in a supermarket
the first time that happened to me where
i was recognized by somebody yeah was it
was before
lord of the rings had come out and i was
so i was like 23 or 22 or something but
i was walking through a supermarket
buying pasta and i'd done some
pressing stuff oh no the first media
come out i could correct myself and this
woman came up behind me and it only just
released then she whispered into my ear
are you my elf
and i was like
no you've got
unknown some pasta
go around encouraging kids to be nice to
each other and not to bully each other
that's a good thing to do
particularly not to bully the the gay
kids in school or indeed the gay members
of staff and and uh so i i was is this
leading on to a little clip yeah i love
this gift yeah yeah and uh
so i was with the head teacher and and
and some of the the senior students but
outside
the head teacher's window there was a
crowd of really small kids who wanted to
have a look so i i i pulled up the blind
and had a chat with them so this is
where is it near bristol somewhere yeah
yeah
and it went viral kind of
viral man
went all over the place this is ian at
the school
in your preparation for your
examinations
if you don't do your revision properly
do you know what will happen
you shall not
though josh you have almost a phobia of
doing action i can't do them
have you ever had to do them no okay
well but occasionally you'll be in a
situation where someone will go oh like
can you do an australian accent or
whatever i just
i just can't do it
and like it makes me like um stressed
like my hands go like when i'm stressed
my hand goes like that
and that and
the thought i i can't like comprehend
how you would even start to like
like thinking about it like
like i can't do it i just i've got this
this is it
and it's not ideal
but you but you you did aspire to be an
actor you well you nearly worked with
martin freeman didn't you i nearly
worked instead of martin franklin
so oh wait a minute i knew so did you
audition for the hobbit you auditioned
for the actual hobbit
certain build by baggins
it was a very close run thing i can
imagine yeah who got it
yeah so i got asked whether i'd audition
for the hobbit
i think on site alone
like come on like you'd think right and
then i turned up and i was absolute dog
[__]
i thought that like i thought i'm not
gonna get this obviously
but
look at me
i'm gonna get some extras work in new
zealand yes
yes that was very quick sorry
i mean what are you talking about but in
venus you are wearing almost a josh
whitaking wig
[Laughter]
you're nearly in it that was the worst
fit i left they said can we have your
hat
do you remember what bit of you had to
do in the audition well i don't
i don't mean no offense but i'm not into
fantasy at all no you're just like
children's [__] [__]
mark ruffalo accused me of being a
pedophile
oh that's followed me around for five
years yeah and every time i meet someone
to go oh ruffalo was a bit horrible too
and now it's happened again if it
happens once
it might be unfortunate it happens twice
from two unconnected people
oh god i'm going to get in a police car
and you're going to be in the front in
the liverpool accent
and you're going to be expected to do
scout as well
but no a lot of people in britain went
up for bilbo
nice i'm just saying no it wasn't only
me and you why are you even michelle
because it's the last time i eat you yes
you've become a tiny bit older
[Applause]
i cannot recommend it strongly enough
it's wonderful
people give you parties and and and send
you cards and presents and and come and
see you in the seat and i'm having a
lovely time and was it wise they gave
you a surprise party at 80.
yes i think they were a little bit
frightened i might have a heart attack
but
that would be the end of it
it was the most blissful thing and what
was nice was your party was kind of back
in your old something ground
yes it was my old school boats in school
where i was brought up and it was the
day before my birthday and i thought i
was just going out for an indian meal
actually
and uh i was having i did have an indie
meal but it was at school with a with
150 people some of them some had flown
in from la and uh it wasn't me no it
wasn't you
you weren't invited because you didn't
remember working with me
now
no i wasn't in charge of the list so you
can't blame me i was invited either no
um
i do remember working with you
but now somebody made an extraordinary
cake oh they did yes it was so
extraordinary that
i couldn't bear to cut it
and if only you could see it you would
understand why well we can see some of
it yes because uh so it was you
essentially the cake
oh yeah it was a likeness of me but
people at the body
well i cut into it was a sort of a bust
on a prince and i cut through the prince
but i mean i couldn't offer someone an
ear or a nose
well now because we have it oh my god
now this you've kept this but i'm i'm
keeping you this comes from my fridge
it's a likeness but i wouldn't call it
flattering
what it seemed to me is it's not really
like me but it's like a character that i
might play do you think yes i think i
could play that yeah do you not think
yes but you can't eat it you could have
us we could have a bite actually have
you have you been nibbling no
well we'll once all that down your suit
that's not you
but thank you is it refrigerated there
yes
that's a working fridge
um we have it on set for just these
but this is lovely so uh one of your old
x-men uh he made a fuss about your
birthday oh was people sent messages and
they were invited to do that and
the suddenly
know
not even a message why should we even
sit with you
here we are now this could be another
party we've got a cake and we're all
together is it yes
[Applause]
ian it's yours
yes are you going to tell this story
yeah well
i just saw the end result suddenly onto
the screen at my old school i saw uh
hugh jackman
and 30 000 people uh and he was playing
in manchester i was just eight miles
away in bolton and they all sang happy
birthday oh we've got the we got the
clip this is this is yes this is him
singing her birthday to you with all
these people
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
and uh and kate now you've done loads of
accents and loads of voices and you know
we would say oh what role would you like
to play what voice would you like to do
and it's a very
i i was surprised by the answer to that
question what was that what was the
answer uh apparently it's it's a name
beginning with l
oh you mean lucy yes i love lucy
no no it's my favorite thing it's it's
lucy from a good man charlie brown
peanuts peanuts lucy yes but you nearly
got to play it well no because i yes
cause one of my close friends is jeffrey
rush and he played snoopy and i'd i'd
always wanted to play lucy where did
this happen
he's done it i've missed it did you see
that bird it's called an eagle but
because it's little it has another name
a sparrow and a christmas of
thanksgiving we eat them and way up
there
[Applause]
those tiny little black things those are
bugs they make the grass grow
oh my god did i get the rolls
i know all the words i know
i think that's really embarrassing but
now elijah
do you find
no just because because you're in such
an iconic film is there a thing where
people just want to say
i shagged frodo
[Applause]
they're earthly folk
um
i don't know i've not really had that
experience i've not i don't feel like
i've been approached by people that i
would question
why
so you people haven't wasted it in your
it's so ears
[Music]
people i certainly have met people like
that they tend to be a little bit older
what's happening backstage very quickly
it is uh oscar's weekend this weekend
and uh ian would you mind telling us the
story about when you were nominated for
uh
gandalf
and you had the the beads yeah
well they weren't beads
in in
new zealand where we filmed lord of the
rings
[Applause]
if you're lucky when you leave you're
given a piece of green stone carved and
you wear it often enough and your
chances are you'll get back to new
zealand that's the idea
and it'll bring you a bit of luck so uh
when those films were nominated for
something like 20 oscars uh on that
night everybody from new zealand was
wearing the green stone that pounami
they're called
uh and when we're on the red carpet
going into the ceremony i met maggie
smith
what what are you here for i said well
i said well lord of the rings oh yeah
she said what's that round your neck oh
so it's my punami maggie
i own your punami what's that if i said
well if i wear it it'll it'll bring me
luck and
oh very nice
and we went our separate ways and you
know it lasts for three and a half or
four hours you know don't you oh yeah
and sit there and at the end of course
everyone else wins the oscar apart from
you
i'm a bit dejected you're coming out
looking forward to a drink and you bump
into maggie smith and she points at you
and it didn't work didn't it
elijah you must have the most amazing
night when lord of the rings what it
equals the most most oscar wins of all
time it equals the record it was surreal
it was 11 yeah i think it was the most
ever nominated and won together yeah wow
but then i'd love this you didn't go to
all the kind of proper like you didn't
go to the vanity fair parties or any of
that
tell us where you went
the onering.net
um
the fans basically of lord of the rings
had their own party the one ring party
celebrating the oscars and we went to
that party
and billy boyd
is wonderful that's great and we
actually i believe we took the oscars
there and displayed them i think pete
showed up and everything billy boyd sang
uh dominic monaghan sang
it was this a joyous beautiful event
we ended up staying there all night we
thought we were just going to show up
and kind of make an appearance and thank
everyone for for having a great party in
our honor and it was the best we just
stayed there we had a videotape later
called hobbits gone wild
what big feet moving on
it was a beautiful night because we felt
like
we i mean they were celebrating this
thing with us and you know so many of
the people who who were part of making
the films were there at the oscars that
night and we were it was a big family
you know we were celebrating as a family
it was beautiful and was it the oscars
uh no golden globes i think where you
were was jack nicholson backstage yeah
were you waiting to go on with jack
nicholson i was waiting to go on to
present an award jack was back there
yeah this is good
jack was back there and dustin hoffman
was back there and um somehow lord of
the rings came up in conversation and he
stood he stood there and he said you
know
i can't do a job well you can do it no i
won't i actually won't do it because
you're too good
but he basically said
you know that movie
it just had so many endings
it just wouldn't end
and he said to me that he actually
walked out before the end he said oh
that's how it started he said what
happened
[Applause]
and i said jack what do you mean
what happened he said well tell me what
the end was
and i said well you know at the end uh
the hobbits are saying goodbye to each
other and frodo gets on the boat and
sails into the undying lands he said i
didn't even see it i walked out before
so he was basically complaining that
there were just too many endings to the
throats
i had to go outside for a little
medication
when i won my academy award he was there
he won this was his third academy award
we're standing backstage because they're
just about to take you to the press
conference and he goes you know robbo
now i have one for every decade
[Music]
you